in cosmology we believe that the
universe started off in a Big Bang 13.7
billion years ago all alternatives have
been pretty much ruled out steady-state
theories other alternatives have been
ruled out however how will the universe
end we have several possibilities one
possibility is a Big Crunch when the
universe squashes together in a gigantic
ball of flame and maybe bangs once again
another possibility is the big freeze
that the universe expands it just keeps
on going and we're all going to freeze
to death and we're all going to die when
the universe reaches near absolute zero
then there's something called the big
rip where the universe goes into an
exponential expansion and expand so
rapidly that the distant galaxies can no
longer be seen because they travel
faster than the speed of light that even
the distant galaxies break the light
barrier and that's called the big rip
meaning that the night sky will be
totally black except for some of the
nearby stars which of the three
alternatives is the fate of the universe
well the short answer is we don't know
however what we do know is that the
universe is undergoing an exponential
runaway expansion the universe at the
present time is careening out of control
every astronomy textbook says that there
was the Big Bang the universe is
expanding but it's slowing down it also
says that the universe is mainly made
out of atoms every textbook says that
the universe is made out of atoms the
universe is expanding but slowing down
both are wrong we have to rewrite every
single high school textbook on the
planet Earth the universe is not mainly
made out of atoms four percent of the
universe is made out of atoms just four
percent twenty three percent is made out
of dark matter seventy three percent
which makes up most of the universe is
dark energy and unfortunately we are
clueless as to what dark energy is and
what dark matter is
in fact if you ever find out what dark
energy and dark matter is be sure to
tell me first now why is that important
because the amount of matter and energy
in the universe determines the rate of
expansion we now know there's a lot more
dark energy that we previously thought
therefore the universe is undergoing an
inflationary exponential expansion it is
in a runaway mode but here's the catch
we don't know how long that runaway mode
is going to last some people say that
it's temporary we're in this huge
expansion right now exponential
expansion but it's going to reverse
itself instead of a red shift will have
a blue shift as the universe collapses
at the present time we simply don't know
why don't we know because we don't know
what dark energy is in fact if you were
to try to write down a theory of dark
energy your number would not correspond
to the data by a mismatch of 10 to the
120 that is the largest mismatch in the
history of science there is no mismatch
bigger than 10 to the 120 so this is a
mystery until we solve the mystery of
dark energy we do not know the ultimate
fate of the universe my personal
thoughts are that perhaps we will
continue with this exponential expansion
and perhaps go into a big rip mode and
at that point all intelligent life in
the universe will die all the tears and
all the struggles and all the heartbreak
of humanity since we rose from the swamp
it's all for nothing why should you
bother to wake up tomorrow knowing that
we're all going to die billions and
billions of years from now when the
universe turns to absolute zero when the
Stars blink out when we'd have nothing
but neutron stars and black holes what's
it all mean anyway if we're all going to
die in a big rip well my personal
attitude is that when the universe is
about to die
why not leave the universe trillions of
years from now we will have the ability
to bend space and time into a pretzel
we'll be able to tie space into knots
we'll be what is called a type 3 maybe a
type 4 civilization a galactic
civilization with the capability of
harnessing galactic power at that point
when the universe becomes so cold that
all life is freezing to death I say let
us escape the universe go into
hyperspace and go to another universe